we are we are proud when I say proud we
are proud parents of a child in the
lgbtq+ community Dwyane Wade is one
proud dad the former NBA star dropped by
Ellen on Tuesday and opened up about
supporting his 12 year old Ziya who
identifies as part of the lgbtq+
community first of all me and my wife my
wife Gabrielle Union we are we are proud
when I say proud we are proud parents of
a child in the lgbtq+ community and we
proud allies as well
and we take our rose and our
responsibility as parents very seriously
Dwayne and Gabrielle have been married
for five years when our child comes home
with a question and a child comes home
with the issue when a child comes home
with anything it's odd job as parents to
listen to that to give them the best
information that we can the best
feedback that we can and that doesn't
change because sexuality is now involved
in it dwayne opened up about the moment
saya who was assigned male at birth and
was named zion shared that she wanted to
be referred to with female pronouns
Zaha 12 year old came home first died
and everybody I don't know everyone
knows originally named Zion Zion born as
a boy came home and said hey so I want
to talk to you guys you know I think
going for it I'm ready to live my truth
and I want to be a references that she
and her I would love for you guys to
call them Isaiah and so internally now
is our job to one go out and get
information to reach out to every
relationship that we have and that
included the cast of a little show oh
you know you might have heard of it pose
yeah pose the FX series that features
many lgbtq+
actors and characters my wife reached
out to everybody on the cast of pose
we're just trying to figure out as much
information we can to make sure that we
give our child the best opportunity to
be you know her best self
on Tuesday pose stars Angelica Ross and
Michael Street took to Twitter to
praised Wayne and Gabrielle Michael
writing quote the part of this story
that is so small but I love so much is
that Gabrielle called up the cast of
pose on FX and was like help meanwhile
Angelica tweeted that she was so touched
when the actress reached out adding that
they are committed to getting it right
as parents quote so looking forward to
Queen Z's schooling all of y'all and
Dwayne he agrees the 38 year old told
Ellen that part of supporting his kid
comes with being a voice for her until
she can be a voice for herself once iron
came home and said hey up and called me
SIA and I'm ready to take on this I
looked at it said you are a leader you
are a leader in its opportunity to allow
you to be a voice right now it's to us
because she's 12 years old but
eventually it would be to her Dwayne who
is also a dad to 1 year old Kavya six
year old Xavier 18 year olds there as
well as a guardian to his 18 year old
nephew previously opened up about
supporting Ziya during an interview on
the all the smoke podcast and applauded
her for having strength and courage I
watched my son from they wanted becoming
to who she now eventually is coming to
you know say and for me it's all about
nothing changes in my love right
nothing changes of my responsibilities
right you know I'm saying so I don't
think I got to do now is get smarter and
educate myself more true and that's my
job and he had this to say to all the
haters all these people does out there
saying those things look at yourself
understand that you don't want to got
the issues you don't want got the
problems it's not the kids how about get
used to it man this is them they're
normal
as for Dwayne and Gabrielle they
couldn't be freaking cuter whatever seat
sent me to where that's what I put on et
caught up with a couple on Sunday during
their casual no big deal date night to
the Vanity Fair Oscars after parties you
look amazing you guys Vanity Fair's
- fabulous chic glamorous night why did
you want to come out tonight and party
this is his first one you know he'd
retired this year so I actually have my
date back so we're really excited I just
wanted him to get the full experience of
this whole Oscar weekend so that this is
the only party to be at well it's
official I couldn't love these two
anymore they're not just couple goals
they're freakin family goals of course
et will be here to bring you all the
latest on Dwayne and Gabrielle so make
sure to keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens see you
soon
[Music]